à franchement alors on sent la peur
parce que vous allez vous mettre bien au
centre de la piste mokhtar
[Applaudissements]
or
jean clair
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais ça a
[Applaudissements]
m bah oui mais toi là à mon bébé
regardait sans déconner on dirait une
famille en or
réalisateur quand je dis une famille
andorre vous prenez chaque caméra voilà
c'est ça faites-moi 10 ans du
réalisateur vous faites moi non mais
sans rigoler je suis obligé de réaliser
les missions ne me dites pas qu'il ya un
truc qui marche pas le mélangeur au
meilleur sur n'importe quoi vous voyez
bien voilà ça c'est un plan une famille
en or par contre définis-tu rejoint le
groupe en tête je te vois ce temps-là il
n'inquiète pas mais toi côté vraiment il
t'arrivera rien de mal raymond et bien
sûr outils
avec toute la route qui le fait à l
abandon plus de faire n'importe quoi par
géra d'imad et comment ça marche et rien
n'a très bien bah ouais alors tu es bien
de hausse commencé d'être dans le public
bah franchement c'est très bien je parle
à des gens très sympathiques terme
allait bien j'adore cette émission mais
michalak pas mal ouais
la sers bien
raison dans nos marchés
qu'est ce que tu dis vous avez des gens
dedans romain d'alors c'est mon portable
mais c'est dingue
et touré dirais c'est vrai qu'on a une
famille à tpm pays seront parler d'une
famille en or et c'est vrai que alors et
on aime tout commença dans mathieu
mathieu qui a rejoint
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous étiez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez acheté les mardis
tout je suis là je croyais pas